las labores de búsqueda y rescate en mi
Pro continúan los servicios de
emergencia han estado trabajando
incansablemente desde el ataque del
sábado por la tarde a temperaturas bajo
cero un grupo de bomberos encontró una
mujer con vida más de 18 horas después
de que el edificio Residencial fuera
alcanzado pero las esperanzas de
encontrar más supervivientes se
desvanecen con decenas de residentes a
un desaparecidos dos escaleras Fueron
destruidas por el misil que según el
ejército ucraniano era un kh 22 lanzado
desde la región rusa de krustk
la explosión fue muy larga nos pareció
muy larga mi hijo y yo gritábamos tanto
que me dolía la garganta las autoridades
rusas negaron su responsabilidad en el
ataque
las fuerzas armadas rusas no atacan ni
edificios residenciales ni
emplazamientos de infraestructuras
civiles los ataques se dirigen contra
objetivos militares tanto evidentes como
camuflados
en su discurso nocturno el presidente
prometió que continuaría la búsqueda de
supervivientes
estamos luchando por cada persona la
operación de rescate durará mientras
exista la más mínima posibilidad de
salvar vidas quiero decir a todos los
que en Rusia o desde Rusia ni siquiera
Ahora son capaces de pronunciar unas
palabras de condena sobre este terror
vuestro silencio cobarde y vuestro
intento de esperar a que pase lo que
está pasando Solo conseguirá que estos
mismos terroristas vengan un día a por
vosotros Rusia también atacó el mismo
día provocando más apagones y poniendo
fin a una pausa de dos semanas en los
ataques aéreos que ha lanzado contra
infraestructura energética y centros
urbanos de Ucrania desde octubre